we listened to this tv show the ghost
story oh yes where you whip out that
story about a ghost living in your
apartment true it's not true listen to
me why don't you take a camera out and
and videotape the ghost and then you
would be the the biggest thing on
television why why would you not do that
if you see a vision of a ghost in your
apartment
look i'm getting quiet because i'm
thinking this is not stupid i am very
comforted with her listen to me she's
still there she's there i was at that
place the other day i was wondering is
this the ghostly i would have taken you
upstairs really i love you
you're one of the smartest people i know
you're a rational person
i want you to look at me seriously
seriously you're telling me there's such
a thing as ghosts yeah okay so you're
not afraid to die because you now know
there's an afterlife you've met a ghost
uh i'm not afraid to die because it's
it's almost time you know what i'm
saying yeah
joan
listen to me you could have real friends
you don't need imaginary friends
you're still popular you don't it's so
sad should i come visit you that was the
last time you came to my appointment
that's true nobody visits you every
video's beautiful take me through i know
you've been through this a million times
at this tv show i felt you did it
because listen it's a tv show why not
you go on you get paid and this and that
i don't believe you believe there was a
ghost i had an exercise i brought in
sally ann glassman from new orleans you
are kidding me no how much did you pay
her to get rid of yourself that's how
you know she's good
listen to me you've gone insane
you've gone you've literally gone insane
14 years ago when i first moved into the
apartment
you came into the apartment i want to
understand everything because i want you
to and i want you to be straight with me
yeah because i would love to believe
they were ghosts i'd be thrilled to meet
a ghost you know why because that means
i'm gonna go on i'm gonna i'm gonna have
a life and ghost i have my friend tommy
corcoran who is now in my country house
in connecticut oh you've got another one
the guy who died he's living in your
house he's in my house in connecticut
he's been seen by four different people
and i am so don't you think joan and her
friends are insane well what are they
going to say when jones says did you see
tommy of course you know what's even
worse my luck i'm going to die and spend
eternity in joan river's apartment
i mean i'll be like i can't believe i'm
i'm watching joe rivers on dressing the
only thing is you you hate the music
because it's awesome oh my god that'll
be hell
all right let me understand something
you walk into your apartment this was
when it was being renovated all right
you walked in and i know you heard
noises and it got caught i wouldn't come
in dog wouldn't come in
whatever
that there's all probable explanations i
want to know right now for my audience
you saw mrs spencer
i
felt mrs spencer i have never seen mrs
spencer and what about your friend tommy
cochran have you seen him i have not
seen but others have seen him
but he left something that i found
he said tell joan uh there's something
that she's looking for and it's down in
the basement and woody who did he tell
them
i have a lady who works for me who's a
psychic
and uh how much money are they cleaning
you out of hey
what is the matter with you you're so
lonely
you need a date i'm going to hook you up
don't worry we're going to help you out
let's get him his physical first now i
see how serious it is spirits get
through dinner
oh joan this is so sad through dinner
tommy cochran said i could i had put his
ashes right just sprinkle in connecticut
okay way up in my attic go ahead and
they were left there and we couldn't
find them and couldn't find it i
couldn't find this man's ass couldn't
find me and ashes you know yeah i mean
you had you knew they were in the attic
yeah and uh he said to this lady uh i
tell her look in the basement there's
something in the basement
and i went down the base and there were
the ashes
nobody knew what was in them and how
they got that so how special could this
guy have been to you if you lost his
ashes
i mean really well i put them up there i
don't know how he but you're always
asking for some my mother died and i was
in california and my mother was in new
york and i said give me a sign give me a
sign i bought my mother a little a lot
of these things happening a little um
gold
uh fish right and i opened my medicine
chest in california and there was the
fish on the shelf